- guys sit down and break the fever how
does this issue the running one area in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
we just need more than ever because you
know how it is not so I try to give a
friend but you knew it
[Applause]
[Music]
watching that show introduce myself as
well I love wrong looking to that tent
on the result from p1p business
development taking further further away
got you gay and then
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
like
[Music]
and television over there like all kind
of litter with Martellus he comes up
everywhere every year which is not the
dinner I don't mark the problem wall
popovers I want to continue a shorter
amount of babies is our Super Bowl
[Applause]
[Music]
and Barry
repeat repla you know maybe here out
here
[Music]
what was your name Jenny Williams it's
all good
[Applause]
we started era we got people to keep
making small over 10 years so hey
everybody this is Charlie just a bit of
an intact here I'm going to do a follow
up breakdown of all the really important
stuff they dropped in this you may have
picked up on it they confirm season for
the flash will not have a big bad that's
a speedster they says it episode 19 will
be the once and future flash that's a
very very seminal reverse flash origin
story but it's about Barry so that
implies some really heavy savatage stuff
they tease the true for an eye crossover
coming next season so I'll do a
breakdown video and post that tomorrow
will be a new round of the flash ring
giveaway while you wait that click here
for this week's flash and click here for
the trailer for the next episodes a big
musical crossover thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five from
behind the screen I'll see you guys in
the next video
you